vous engager pour le moment. »
Car bien sûr, n'oublions pas que nous parlons de drones,
une technologie qui n'est pas uniquement impopulaire en occident,
mais qui s'est également convertie en
réalité profondément pénible pour de nombreuses villes victimes de pauvreté
notamment, celles victimes de conflits.
Alors ? Quel est l'objectif ?
Eh bien, nous nous battons,
non pas parce que c'est facile,
mais parce que ça peut avoir un impact hallucinant.
Imaginez un million de personnes connectées
aux biens matériaux de la même manière
que les télécommunications mobiles les connectaient
à l'information.
Imaginez si l'énorme réseau à venir que nous bâtissons dans le monde
était un réseau de transport de matière.
Dans les pays en voie de développement, nous pouvons espérer
atteindre alors des millions de personnes avec des vaccins et médicaments
de meilleure qualité.
Cela nous avantagerait injustement dans la lutte contre
les virus du VIH/SIDA, la tuberculose et autres épidémies.
Avec le temps, nous espérons qu'il se changera
en une nouvelle plateforme de transactions économiques,
pouvant extraire des millions de personnes de la pauvreté.
Et dans les pays développés et émergents,
nous espérons qu'il deviendra un nouveau mode de
transport, aidant ainsi à rendre nos villes
plus vivables.
Alors, pour ceux qui pensent encore que c'est de la science-fiction,
je suis catégorique sur le fait que ça ne l'est pas.
Toutefois, nous devons nous engager
dans la "social fiction" pour parvenir à un résultat.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)